look at you miss christmas
[Laughter]
how are you i'm pregnant i'm so good i'm
so happy
we're thriving over here we're doing
good how are you i gotta know
really great before we get to a very
train of christmas i have to know
because
i dealt with students they dealt with my
girlfriend was pregnant over the
holidays and i need to know this
the holidays are full of tastes and
smells that you don't normally
experience throughout the year
how are you going to handle all of this
are there things that you cannot be
around are there things that have
changed
i'm excited because i i haven't had one
of those like
i smell something terrible i just
noticed that i smell
stronger than everyone else like i get
to the smell first
but um i'm excited because the only
thing i'm craving is sweets which is
dangerous
so we're trying to make like sugar-free
or like sneak it like
keto you know because i'm i could eat
like a whole bag of
lollipops right now are you having
been have dealing with the living with
the schedule that you've had for so many
years
right now being able to just sort of sit
and
chill and be pregnant and wonderful like
are you just
like in the best place ever right now
i'm so
busy right now
i'm so tired bro
i literally i've been working since
i mean we i was doing a whole promo for
treat myself my last album
and then as soon as it came out we had
corona
and i was also doing the voice uk so i
had like a few months of like we were
all terrified in corona and quarantine
and um i had a few months of like what
do we do
and then we immediately were like okay
let's go help feeding america and let's
do something while we're home
and that turned into okay i think we'll
be here for a minute
let's make a baby did that and at the
same time we're like let's do my
christmas album while we're here it's at
home it'll be quick easy
i'm doing a christmas stuff while i'm
pregnant so yeah we've recorded
performances i tried to record all the
performances
before i got like monstrously big so
yeah
doing music videos and performances that
no one's even seen yet
and now we're doing all the promo and
i'm just like
it's it's nice though that i get the
luxury of being home like i'm
on my kitchen table right now but um
we're working
pretty sure okay explain to me this like
when you say
let's make a christmas album and make a
baby was it really like this
like what is it i got so lucky i didn't
even go i i'm no i'm
so like i know how hard it is to get
pregnant for a lot of people out there
and i didn't know if i would like
struggle or not
um i probably should have went to the
doctor and been like how's it going but
it was too scary it was like corona time
so i just like youtubed it um i
also got a lot of stuff and i we
accomplished our goal in three months we
did it we got very lucky
and good for you yeah i couldn't believe
it but yeah i was
i was doing my research i figured it out
i did it i was very lucky
uh when it comes to putting a christmas
album together mixing originals with
classics and then deciding which
classics to include
is a daunting task for anyone because
these are
precious gems for a lot of people what
was your take on sort of reworking
a lot of things that people already love
oh man uh well i just have like weird
connections with songs
like um i lived in ben crosby's house
so i knew i wanted to do white christmas
like weird
ghost stuff like that um because he sang
the first one and
um i also love white christmas because
michael buble like raised me so i know i
knew like oh these are precious moments
i also know where my voice sits i know i
can't take on him or i carry song
i know i'm not gonna be like yeah i'll
try all i want for christmas is you no
let the queen sing it and i also know
like oh holy night when you hit the high
notes i'm like
let's pick silent night and let's do
something quiet like let's
i know where my range is and the easiest
part was writing songs
like people were like were you nervous i
was like no that was like the easy part
the hard part was like
how do i make these covers how do i give
justice to these amazing songs
years ago i asked this question to anne
murray
the queen of christmas in canada when
when it's christmas morning and you have
the choice to put something on
are you going to put your music on to
wake up to christmas morning
112
days it will be my album on repeat
and then i'll go give us like a splash
of
frank sinatra's christmas albums and
michael buble and then i'll bring it
back
to me uh do you remember when
before things sort of clicked for you
and before you
you you blew up once that happened and
you had a little bit of money do you
remember that first sort of indulgent
gift
that you bought for somebody else that
you never thought you'd be able to
afford
yes let me tell you what it is yes
please
um yes it was a house for my mom and paw
always like joked around and told him
like one day oh my good you a house
in hawaii but it was in hawaii it was
california and it was four minutes from
my house
so um i did it though and they like
picked it out with me and it was like a
dream come true
of mine and my mom's like please take it
back we don't deserve this and i'm like
you deserve more than this so
sit with it um your your brother worked
on the record is your dad on this record
yes my dad is playing the piano of have
yourself a merry little christmas
and it's just him and i singing it and
we were in two different rooms but i was
like
okay dad hit it and we sang it like live
together so it's very
magical very special something i'll
never forget and he
rehearsed all week he was so excited and
so nervous
it's so cute because he's so talented
but he still gets nervous and he's like
i need to practice
now at that point is he a collaborator
or is he your dad or do you flip back
and forth on how you talk to him
well i've been performing with him since
i was
my little brother's just getting a glass
of eyes um i've been performing with my
dad since church since i was like
five or six so like performing with him
has always been easy and great
and there's something really magical
about like the eye contact you get of
like we're doing this we're doing good
um
so yeah having having that
like a lot of families don't have that
and so having that special moment i was
like we to record this and
and now it's like the best memory we get
to play forever and ever
um your kid's first music video is with
earth winded fire how do you top that
you don't top it it
no more music videos ever for this kid
that's it that's all he needs um he's so
cool already
um i remember like the first shot was
with the band because i was like get
them in
get them home safely like i'll do the
rest and um
no one's even seen this yet it's crazy
and i was dancing in heels which i
haven't done all pregnancy because why
and i remember like i started cramping
up after two hours of that
like my my stomach was cramping and i
think he was like
enough is enough mom
good this has been fun um so yeah i was
just like wow he's so legendary he's so
cool already
and uh if i if i talk to your husband
right now and ask him if you were on the
the the naughty list or the good list
what would he say for this year
you're lucky as headphones in he's like
listening to a book
have i been on the naughty list or the
good list or the nice list
only the nice list he knows what to say
i've trained him
and so do you have traditions like are
you looking forward to sort of building
your own traditions you got the album
the the sort of the the new baby like
what are you looking forward to
doing as a family in sort of your place
moving forward have you thought about
traditions that you want to start
or carry on with i don't know what i
want to start but i know i want to start
new traditions with my husband and my
family and like
start having our own memories it's so
cute um but my dad does this amazing
thing where he gathers everyone around
and holds hands and
we say like a grateful moment a grateful
prayer where we're like
look who's around you look at what's
important in life and like i love you
all and
it's like my favorite thing we do every
year so i'm gonna keep that going as
long as i can
and um and i can't wait to start new
ones i know we do we have been dressing
up more
like every year my brother's santa and
we're elves and i want my baby to be a
reindeer next year like
we're gonna have the best pictures ever
listen i love you so much i always have
i'm proud of you and everything you've
done
and congratulations on everything the
tree behind you looks beautiful i love
your sweater
you did it yeah i did it thank you
i thought these were little ornaments
for your tree that light up turns out
they're like
not fuller i bought four of them they're
all over my house my husband hates me
it's okay
i'm learning how to online shop you
are the best thank you so much and merry
christmas and just all the best
to you and hopefully next time we do
this we'll be able to hang out the same
room
yes we will miss you thank you so much
for your time appreciate it all right
wonderful take it easy bye-bye
thank you
you